des frappes aériennes aussi sur Kiev
c'était hier et là encore une attaque au
drone en plein jour une personne au
moins été tuée selon le maire de la
capitale vitalité au cours des dernières
semaines plusieurs assauts comme
celui-ci on visait la ville on va tenter
de comprendre ce qui est en train de se
jouer dans ce qui s'apparente à une
guerre de drone avec vous Alexandre vaut
travers bonjour à vous vous êtes
rédacteur en chef de la revue militaire
suisse et directeur scientifique au
Centre d'Histoire et de prospective
militaire merci d'avoir accepté
l'invitation de France 24 Alexandre
vautravel on sait qu'une distance d'au
moins 1000 km c'est par Moscou et sa
périphérie de l'Ukraine alors pour
l'instant l'Ukraine de revendique pas
ces attaques c'est la Russie qui accuse
le voisin d'avoir fomenté cet assaut
dans tous les cas quel type de drone
peut frapper à une telle distance bon
ici on est en train de parler de drone
de faible voilure de faible dimension de
faible coût et il y a toute une série de
personnes qui sont relativement méc ente
de soit la guerre en Ukraine soit de la
manière dont elle est menée donc ce ne
sont pas nécessairement des agents
Ukrainiens qui opèrent ces drones à
proximité de Moscou alors quel type
d'appareil vous pensez on évoque souvent
les drones shahids de fabrication
iranienne qui ne coûte pas très cher
mais qui ont une certaine puissance de
frappe c'est à ce modèle d'abord que
vous pensez ensuite de qui parlez-vous
d'après les images que vous avez
montrées il s'agit de système qui
transporte des charges explosives de
quelques dizaines de grammes donc c'est
l'équivalent d'une grenade à main on
peut dire donc c'est quelque chose qui
s'apparente davantage à du bricolage
qu'à quelque chose qui vient de grandes
distances et qui serait produit fabriqué
par des industries de défense
comme je vous l'ai dit il y a toute une
série de personnes en Russie qui soit
sont d'accord de prendre d'accepter de
l'argent soit ne sont pas contents avec
cette guerre soit ne sont pas contents
avec les défaites militaires ou le le
piétinement militaire le fait que les la
situation n'avance pas vous
pensez que j'ai une data qu'il y a
quelques jours sur Belgorod ces deux
groupes
bon tout ceci fait partie d'une
gigantesque opération d'information donc
bien sûr ça c'est un élément un élément
qui est avancé par le gouvernement de
Kiev mais enfin vous avez quand même
toute une série de personnes qui n'ont
pas forcément envie de faire un certain
nombre de mois de service militaires en
Russie en ce moment donc il y a une
sorte de rébellion à l'intérieur même du
territoire russe est-ce qu'on on est en
ce moment dans un nouveau tournant une
nouvelle configuration de cette guerre
on est dans un nouveau tournant dans la
mesure où ces attaques de drones ont
complètement fait oublier la défaite
militaire
ukrainienne du côté de bar mouth et puis
on est aussi dans un tournant parce que
avec l'arrivée de nouveaux matériels la
formation maintenant de 9 brigades
mécanisées et on attend une dizaine
d'autres brigades formées avec du
matériel
occidental pour reprendre des opérations
agressives dynamiques offensive donc on
peut effectivement à s'attendre dans le
courant de l'été à une un retournement
de la situation dans tous les cas c'est
une extension supplémentaire du conflit
et donc qui s'inscrit dans cette grande
contre-offensive annoncée par Kiev
voilà dans 32 c'est finalement pas grand
chose est-ce qu'il s'agira d'une
offensive de deux attaques de quatre
attaques enfin il y a différents
scénarios qui sont possibles je crois
que aujourd'hui on est en train de
comment dire de gérer les attentes parce
qu'on se rencontre qu'avec le
renforcement des lignes russes aussi
bien par des constructions défensives
des champs de mines des défenses en
profondeur et puis aussi le doublement
de l'effectif militaire russe engagé
contre l'Ukraine les offensives auront
probablement moins d'effets
spectaculaires ou décisifs sur le plan
tactique ou opératif que cela n'a été le
cas en août septembre dernier merci
beaucoup Alexandre à travers merci
d'avoir pris le temps de répondre à nos
questions ce matin sur France 24